the people that do not have a broker
like that in their corner are
unbelievably more likely to pull their
money out every time there's bad news
and to put pull their money at exactly
the wrong time and buy at exactly the
wrong time trying to time the market so
if you never pull your money out it's
worth 0.87 just to keep you from jumping
off the cliff just to talk to you off
the ledge just to talk you off the ledge
because you're having a broker in your
corner goes don't do that here's the
historical data here's what happens you
know every year following a two-year
downturn except of one since the 1930s
we've seen a huge uptick we've had two
down years we're going to see a huge
uptick historically coming up most
people don't know that